what book am I reading right now
so I've recently started a habit of
trying to read before going to bed not
having any electronics in the room where
you have our smartphones and our iPads
and laptops all outside the room one for
the alarm when Nina wakes up in the
morning she has to go outside of the
room I can't just snooze and to just
that have a little bit of a quiet time
before going to bed not checking your
phone not having that blue screen kind
of keep you awake all night although i
was up till three in the morning so that
may not be great example I was working
on something it energizes me but a
little tired today almost every night
now I'm trying to read a little bit more
and what I started reading was something
that I've read almost every year so I've
read this book at least a dozen times
and I'm reading it again and it's the
classic think and grow rich and I am
just kind of starting through that one
again one of the books that every time
you read one I get something new from it
and to it kind of helps focus me again
and I'm just a big fan of that book in
general so my question for you guys is
what book are you reading right now and
what book do you like to reread over and
over and over again at least once a year
and get something new from it every time
leaving comments below and I'll join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon